isn't uh blueface's girlfriend who's
insane with no teeth isn't she on one of
those shows yeah babe Chris on Sean
what's her name Christian all right yeah
shout out to her she's have you ever
seen anybody as crazy for like you've
got a homegirl like that that was just
like dick crazy
how about today you know I actually know
somebody who was worse than her really
totally me but
it was you
you're telling me you're worse than
Christian rock at a point in time in
your life
you know I feel like she's kind of
normal besides the tattoo [ __ ] you think
she's normal yeah really yeah you know
that
she broke into his house cut herself
open
drew a love letter to him in Blood and
then stole his G-Wagon and drove it
across the country and was found in like
Kentucky like three days later you
really mate
Google that [ __ ] I swear
I didn't make that up that happened
he's looking so seriously nice
I swear I didn't make it up up
I didn't make it up you got to see this
it's listen Okay it shot me
Rock
uh stole carb I'm just gonna type it
blood
[Laughter]
sounds like a [ __ ] great album
all right uh blueface began and around
okay here we go
blueface knows his former artist Krishan
Rock stole his car and he's sharing all
the evidence to prove it in a lengthy
series of Instagram story posts on
Tuesday blueface began to unravel an
array of text messages between him
before she reportedly stole his G-Wagon
she wrote I love blue in Blood and then
stole his [ __ ] car
that's quite normal to me I was gonna
say
tell me about the time you went to jail
for a boyfriend because apparently you
[ __ ] you're turned up oh no so what
was what what's the craziest thing
you've done because this girl beat the
[ __ ] out of monkey
so what have you done
have you ever have you ever chopped up
clothes yes that's happened to me yeah I
did it twice
damn which you know I had to stop so I'm
like okay I don't want nobody [ __ ] with
my [ __ ] right but um
I tried to kill them I tried to like
make my gun go blah blah
well I uh
you try to kill it what did you cheat on
you
okay so like the first time no this all
happening once so bam I went to the club
keep on texting me back you know he had
the location oh so you had his location
so you know yeah okay and so I wouldn't
know trying to fight
but then he was getting embarrassed so
he would like go to the back so we went
to the back and so I did that he hit my
head back I'm like [ __ ] so oh he hit
you back yay no human baseball so
I went to my girl I said I went I went
in my pocket like I normally have my gun
in my purse she just by the way you got
into the club with a gun no problem yeah
oh it's clean it was in Frazier okay
okay
so yeah I know I'm gonna have my gun in
my purse and he know that but I I didn't
walk in the club my purse because I
didn't want nobody to notice me because
I walked in the club without black on
like oh he was he was on a mission you
were straight disguised yes I'll put the
gun in my hoodie in the front Jesus so
he didn't know I had it so that's why he
hit me because he did he knew I uh she
had his ass so he did that but we kind
of came off a little bit so I went in my
pocket inside I went in my pocket he
sawed it like dude he ran so [ __ ]
they were like well I'm glad that that
didn't happen you know yeah but look I
was trying to act like I was cool the
next day like I was like
like I wasn't mad no more but I was
telling my friend I'm like as soon as he
come I had a pillow right here
and I'm just gonna shoot
me well [ __ ] he knew that I was gonna do
that like he was like no oh you guys uh
did you guys like end up staying
together after this
or was that like the last straw or did
you guys keep it going for a little
longer
yeah it was the last straw for like
three days and then it was back running
back
where's he at now
I think he died
[ __ ] did you you didn't kill him
obviously
[Laughter]
okay
[Laughter]